breaking news here in sledgehammer  county after a sharp increase of car  racing activity in recent days  authorities now report a staggering  amount of items and race tracks popping  up out of nowhere  jan  what do you make of it  well bill it's like you say random bits  and pieces of race tracks along with all  different kinds of items have been  emerging all over the county and wait  i'm just getting word that these pieces  now seem to be rising into the air  forming an ever-expanding aerial  racetrack and eclipsing the sky above  sledgehammer  bill  i've never seen anything like this  you have to wonder who is behind this  and  where does it end shadows  [Music]  targets in their side  running  out of life  to  [Music]  you say your last goodness  so  you